the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a breakdown video today I want to take a
look at some of the new images from the
second episode I don't know how many of
you saw these but HBO did release some
new photos taken from the next episode
and some of these are from scenes that
we did not see in any other trailers
let's go ahead and take a look at some
of them then try to figure out what else
could happen in the next episode the
very first image I want to look at is
bran stark out near the weirwood tree in
the godswood I think there is a lot to
be taken away from this photo because of
what bran stark still needs to do before
the night Kings army arrives for the
battle as of right now we have still not
seen Jon Danni brain Sam or anyone else
come up with a strategy for the battle
against the night King like I said
another video Samwell Tarly needs to
find some new information in those books
he took from the Citadel there is a
reason why they were mentioned in the
first episode when Danny and Jorah went
to talk to Sam also we need to see bran
start go inside of the weirwood net to
find some answers now that we see bran
stark out here by the weirwood tree I
think that's exactly what he's doing I
did notice that some of he said maybe
bran stark already knows what to do
maybe he has already seen some of the
answers but I don't agree with that
these will be some of the biggest
revelations remaining in the series
there is no way that happens off screen
I think either Sam will find something
in the books then tell bran where to
look or bran will find something on his
own or maybe a little bit of both you
have to remember what uncle Benjen told
brand the last time they spoke one way I
know he will find his way to the wood
and then when he does
you will be there waiting for him and he
will be ready
he told Brian the night king would be
coming and when he does Brian will be
waiting for him
and he would be ready well we already
know bran is literally waiting for the
night cane he set out there in that
courtyard for the entire first episode
although he was waiting on Jamie now
it's time for bran stark to get the work
the night king will be arriving by the
end of this episode that means they need
to find some answers before the episode
ends I think we see them strategizing in
some of the other new photos in this
photo we can see Jon Snow and Samwell
Tarly together it looks like Jon Snow is
looking down at a table since we can see
Samwell Tarly standing right next to Jon
looking at him almost as if he's waiting
for his reaction this could be when Sam
shows Jon something in one of the books
from The Citadel
maybe Sam has found something he thinks
can help Jon during the battle remember
this is one of the main reasons why Sam
went to the Citadel in the first place I
said that because I mean even this was
said to be safe that's all I want
to become a mr. song can help John when
the time comes he wanted to go to try to
find some answers that way he could help
John when the time came for them to
fight the night king like I said in my
last video we could see that Samwell
Tarly was already looking in those books
when Danny came to talk to him I
imagined Samwell find something in the
next episode right before the battle
starts when Sam first gets to the
Citadel we can see him looking inside of
the restricted area of the Citadel in
one of those books that Sam can see
through the cage it does show the phases
of the Moon
maybe that book can explain why the
summers and winters last for so long
george RR martin did say we would find
that out by the end of the story now
when we see Sam go into the Citadel to
take the books with him to Winterfell
the very first thing he does is go
inside of that restricted area so we
know Sam had to have taken some of their
most interesting books now the question
is what can Sam find in the books and
what can bran see inside of the weirwood
net these are the characters that will
give us the most insight into how we can
defeat the night king I have recently
started to think that maybe bran or Sam
can learn something about the night king
symbol he keeps leaving behind as you
all know in the first episode the night
king left them a message
he killed little Ned umber then he had
him mounted to the wall and around his
body was the same symbol we have seen
many different times throughout the
series it's the exact same symbol we
have seen even around the where what
sure you wear the night King was created
we know that symbol has some sort of a
connection to the children of the forest
because of that symbol was already there
as they were creating the night king
since that symbol was located around
their main weirwood tree I believe it
has something to do with their magical
abilities now as we all know bran has
already been at that location several
times when he went inside of the
weirwood net he was there when the night
King was created then he was there again
when the night King was waiting for bran
only this time the weirwood tree was
frozen most likely due to the night
Kings creation when we see the night
Kings eyes start to turn blue I assume
it slowly took over his entire body
turning him into what we see today then
it probably took over that entire area
freezing everything in sight bran stark
may have to go back to that local
and inside of the weirwood net that
location might hold all the answers if
he doesn't have to go back there inside
of the weirwood net then maybe John and
Daenerys need to take the Dragons there
to burn it down just like we saw
symbolized in the first episode if
that's where he's getting all of his
magical abilities from then you might
have to set fire to that location
not only could bran find that out when
we see him by the weirwood tree but
Samwell Tarly may also be able to find
something in those books now remember
that one book in the restricted area had
the phases of the Moon so maybe there is
another book that has those symbols in
it now there is one other x-factor that
we have to consider we still need to see
Melisandre come back to Westeros
Melisandre still has her own part to
play in all of this as well we did not
see Melisandre in the first episode we
still haven't seen her in any other
trailers or new photos either for some
reason they don't want to show us what
Melisandre is up to they don't even want
to give us a glimpse since we know that
the night king will be arriving very
soon
that means Melisandre will have to
arrive very soon as well Melisandre has
to be there during the battle even if
she shows up after the fighting has
already started either way she has to be
there remember what Melisandre said to
John the last time they saw each other
at Winterfell I've been ready to die for
many years if the Lord was done with me
so be it but he's not you've seen the
night King Jon Snow you know the Great
War still to come you know the army of
the Dead will be upon us soon and you
know I can help you win that whoa
Melisandre already knows she can help
Jon win the battle she must have seen
something in the flames that she has yet
to tell us as I said before I think it
has to be some kind of a self-sacrifice
she knows she is meant to die the next
time she returns to Westeros and she
already knows that she is meant to help
defeat the night King so I assumed those
two things are intertwined her sacrifice
will lead to the defeat of the night
king now imagine this imagine if
Melisandre shows up in Winterfell and
it's her that helps bran Stark find some
of the answers we've never seen bran and
Melisandre in any scenes together
those two characters also represent ice
and fire bran is obviously ice and
Melisandre is obviously fire bran is
getting his powers from the old gods
whereas Melisandre is getting hers from
the Lord of Light if those two
characters could somehow combine their
powers they could unleash their own A
Song of Ice and Fire right on the night
Kings ass now think about this I have a
very crazy idea
I doubt it whatever happened but it did
cross my mind and I will be the first
person to admit it does sound crazy in
one of my recent videos I told you that
Melisandre has often talked about
burning down the weirwood trees now we
don't see this as much in the television
show but she does this many times in the
books
Melisandre wants to have every single
where--what tree put to the fire she
even tells this to Jon Snow okay so
since Melisandre said she knows she has
to die and it will most likely be some
sort of sacrifice what if Melisandre
sacrifices herself to the weirwood trees
what if they go to the same weirwood
tree that has that symbol the same
weirwood tree where the night king was
created and where he was waiting for
bran
what if Melisandre has someone tie her
to the tree just like the night king was
tied to the tree then Melisandre has the
fire within her burned down the tree
since she wants everyone to burn down
the trees maybe she has to burn down the
main weirwood tree by sacrificing
herself to that tree if that happened it
would end up looking exactly like the
burning symbol from the first episode
not only when Melisandre died just like
she said but she would also help Jon
defeat the night king just like she said
Melisandre has said time and time again
she has a fire burning inside of her Jon
finds this out when he's riding the
elevator with her maybe Melisandre needs
to unleash her own fire in order to
extinguish the night Kings main power
source which is the tree where he was
created don't forget we have seen
Melisandre sacrifice other characters
like that before
think about the way Melisandre killed
Shireen Baratheon it looks like Shireen
is tied around a tree then she is caught
on fire it would make sense for
Melisandre to go out in a similar
fashion Melisandre could sacrifice
herself in the same way by getting tied
to a tree and having it burnt down only
this time it would be a weirwood tree
that contains all the my king's magic
now I know I know that my
sound crazy but for some reason I did
start to visualize that in my head so I
decided I will talk about it in the
video regardless of how it happens we
need to see bran and Sam start to find
some answers in the next episode now
that all the hugs and kisses are out of
the way it's time for these characters
to start to get to work now let's just
say that the answer is a brain and Sam
fine don't have anything to do with the
symbols then I think it could have
something to do with my other melisandre
theory you know the one where Melisandre
is nice and ISA hopefully all of you
have seen that video by now I just
uploaded it last week in case you have
not seen that video I will leave the
link in my description I do happen to
think that one has enough evidence to be
true but I also kind of like this crazy
one I just told you about either way I
think Melisandre sacrifice could be the
key to stopping the night king anyways
let me know what you think about those
new photos of brain in the godswood and
John and Sam standing over what looks to
be a table do you think this is when Sam
shows John something in the books and do
you think this is when brand goes inside
of the weirwood net to find some answers
let me know what you think down below
thank you all very much for watching
today's video
I also want to thank everyone on patreon
for supporting the channel I really
appreciate that I hope y'all have a
great day I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]